In addition to this
notion of domination,
another thing that's
going to be helpful is,
if I tell you a tale of two
operators for two policies.
So imagine we've got policy Pi(1) and
policy Pi(2).
We're going to define the one step
Bellman operator on those two policies.
So the first operator B1,
when we apply it to a value function V
is just going to return for each state
the immediate reward from that state.
If we follow policy Pi1 plus
the discounted expected value for
following policy Pi1 with
one step look up on V.
So we're converting V, we're basically
putting V through a one step value
iteration with a fixed policy Pi1,
and B2 is the same idea,
same operator,
except with respect to policy two.
Pi2.
So, what we're going to be able to
show is various kinds of interesting
domination relationships between
the value functions that we get
out with each of these operators.